I don't know were you ever in Coleman no
okay call me listen oh that's federal
that's federal
that's better ah yeah yeah oh yeah
Coleman's federal camp that's uh yeah
you got to do like a lot real big [ __ ]
to do that yeah yeah like that's like
the Harvard for criminals I remember
that's where Matt Cox was right yeah but
you remember we've got my cock's big was
either Dave Clark or him yeah number
Dave Clark he's having a woman right now
still oh yeah was that one of your
buddies he's get out sometimes you get
out of those 20 3720 he's done but he
loves God yeah he's super religious that
is that is really all that matters yes
actually in Florida yeah so you didn't
find Jesus actually actually actually I
we didn't we don't get along yeah we
really we really don't get along because
all these Christians out here it's oh
they're always talking about forgiveness
yeah but since I've been out of prison
it's every time I try to go do something
it's like gross you're a felon you can
go [ __ ] off check that box that but
that's like all of our all of our laws
whether you like it or not are based on
Christian values yeah
wait everything is based on Christian
values yeah which they say church and
state is separate is [ __ ] yeah
because it's that whole [ __ ]
forgiveness thing you [ __ ]
[ __ ] that I'd never get forgiven
even when I was in Pennsylvania when we
got the the house to rent yeah there was
a few places that would not even talk to
me because of my background yeah and it
sucks because I don't know just not even
talking to somebody before and just kind
of judge yeah them all in there like
that yeah they don't know you and you
have made like I feel like a full
[ __ ] three oh yeah yeah well cuz I
just you've come from I've learned that
there's more
Jesus Christ there's more it's a bet on
the air you answer it answer it
oh hey what's up babe oh you know it's
[ __ ] sucks these guys [ __ ] don't
know you're a lot your live your live on
the air
you're not live you get your room
cleaned up or what
all right go to bed I'll be home later
love you know we're uh we're still in
our haha we're still in prison
do you want it do you want to tell the
story about how we met yeah heavy sick
yeah what that's an easy one
no no no if you're sleepy go to bed okay
well I'll see you a little bit or a few
hours yeah we'll see what comes first
you're just you're just prolonging it
being on the phone right now you're just
prolonging it being on the phone shout
out shout out to your wife that's all
right yeah how did you meet your wife I
got out in February I met her in May it
was like love at first sight you know I
mean I guess you were there right where
did you meet orchestrated the whole trip
really give us the story like another
thing that helped me and Jake
our relationship was a heavy metal and
you got him into it right yeah I I
helped to guide him towards the healing
powers and righteousness of heavy metal
it is way better than Jesus I highly
recommend heavy metal over justice I
remember is like completely different I
will say Jake did have like the
traphouse gucci mane CD when it first
came out look at this girl cooking at
the stove naked I went through kind of
try to like find yourself and you found
yourself yeah yeah well I mean that's
kind of the problem with down here
because that's like goes back to the
whole thing about nobody's really into
anything down here yeah because you got
all these old [ __ ] and all you do all
they do is drink there's this like
there's really nothing going on around
here if you think about it for for young
people I used to skateboard all the time
yeah I had my hip surgery I couldn't do
that anymore did nothing so I had
nothing I had nothing but drugs and and
rap yeah cuz brew met when I remember
Jake it was like when we were young it
was like the hot boys yeah like big
timers yeah yeah cash money and respect
was like always the party's your house
Jake always had the baddest [ __ ] all
around I remember maybe the first time
were they mom
like the first time I seen a real bear
like women's titties definitely probably
a party at your house always so a girl
screaming from laughs yeah I remember
Luke telling me a story one time he was
like he's like I walked into my room and
there was just this girl and jake was
like yeah go in there and check it out
and they and she was just spread no she
was like she was like Luke sighs I mean
she was like and we were in like middle
school me for sure like the Reddington
Piron smoking black and milds with you
and I was in 6th grade yeah this is
living yeah we would party at the house
and we would go like ride our bicycles
to Luke's house and you would already be
there and all your friends and [ __ ]
mad girls and in the mud and with the
scoreboard on the wall I'm glad you guys
like carry that tradition yeah they're
definitely weighted our scores were
there was only like two of us actually
but that was so sick I just kind of
floated through life my whole yeah not
knowing it wasn't a bat I mean it's not
a bad thing but it's like I kind of went
through life not knowing how to do
anything but [ __ ] party yeah yeah I
mean so but semana I guess I guess
prison probably was the best thing
that's ever happened to me Gianni's
honestly yeah if I had to do it again
the same way I would really yeah could
it'd be dead if it was well I know I
can't die but my life's a lot better
yeah you can
you're eerie immortal I guess that's
right dad so Gabi and it's just it's
just weird how everything kind of just
kind of keeps working out and yeah
learnin [ __ ] I mean I learned more from
prison that I have from anybody in my
whole life
[Laughter]